hey everybody I'm Tiffany Smith about
Kristian harloff and our guests on this
week's episode is Alan do it so thanks
so much Alison for coming to hang out of
us and completing our movie threesome
do you not known each other for a long
time we had about three four days but
you've been crazy busy what's been going
on well we just wrapped up BattleBots we
had our season premiere this past Sunday
did really well so glad we get a second
season in September I'm going to be on
con man which is a show with Nathan
Fillion and Alan Tudyk and that
premieres September 30th on Vimeo I made
a big thing at Comic Con about 7,000
people came and saw our panel at Hall H
is amazing else I don't know if you know
this or not we do a weekly wage rumpus
yes I heard about this I saw the creepy
clown pixels if I'm not mistaken - with
24 million which means I don't I don't
buy it and I found a loophole
international box office behind me up I
got a lipoma ask someone else
hey Simon pay did I win Christian you
lost the bet I really like simon pegg
this week's punishment comes to us from
a youtube comment from Alejandro Flores
and she hosts it loser should cook some
tacos during the show for everyone great
there's tacos it's all about Tom
Cruise's new movie Mission Impossible
rogue nation so are you so excited all
right well let's take a look Tom Cruise
you have to get through 12 feet of
concrete and 70,000 gallons of
pressurized water without any metal no
oxygen tanks did he get eaten by a shark
let's get into our weekly wager I think
it's gonna make 51 million opening
weekend I shall say 45 45 million so
make sure you size that geezer shut on
Facebook
I'm an artist use a stack loser should
on Facebook Twitter in the comments
below and that will be what Christian
has to do next week because he's
probably gonna lose again no I gotta
Bosch I'm taco of course you know the
chicken tacos that I made here they are
done oh the hashtag loser should
Alejandro said you had to make tacos for
everyone everyone
alejandra you can't face this we've
talked about mission impossible here The
Spectre trailer came out I mean Hunger
Games is coming out Jurassic Park was
huge it's been an action movie episode I
have a question what do you guys think
is the most dangerous movie that has
ever been made and I don't mean
dangerous where someone unfortunately
has died like The Twilight Zone I'd be
terrible I mean a movie where someone
should have died but didn't pitch
perfect - what rebel Wilson did all our
own stunts I'm going mad max fury road I
don't know how that guitar player stayed
on that vehicle while it was moving so
quickly I want to show you guys a clip
of a movie that maybe some of you guys
out there have heard of maybe you didn't
it's a little film called roar have you
guys heard of this oh there are injuries
to the cast the crew scalp wounds took
11 years to complete this movie those
are untrained lights this is the basis
of Jurassic Park this is all real stuff
here I'm Melanie Griffith by the way why
is the crew - not acting because she's
terrified yeah I would not be surprised
that this film was actually written by
lines where we want to get some snacks
gathered oh we used to do a movie like
this like watching a live-action Lion
King as Mufasa hold a switchblade yes so
that's what I'm saying as far as a movie
that is the most dangerous movie would
you be able to do that this movie but I
never actually saw the trailer and it's
I don't have words so can we just think
game and this particular game is called
bizarre world theater I'm going to tell
them a title for example live soft here
we go
empty liquid pants empty Full Metal
Jacket
oh yeah nice liquid metal ordinary woman
normal man extraordinary True Lies I
just why women x-men the white square
the heavy night the dark night final one
here and this is gonna neither bloodbath
here you're gonna walk away to the point
okay
yes State for young dudes as tough as
that was and as hard as Tiffany finally
got it Alison you're sweet that just
means to do you get to make us do
whatever you want I'm going to dump the
M&Ms on my face no I'm subject that's
what I'm gonna do
well I'd like to thank our guest today
Alison Haislip for joining us then
Alison's me follow her at Alison Haislip
and make sure that you subscribe to this
YouTube channel
download the Fandango movie clips app on
your smartphone and then join us back
here
on hey Christian you lost the bet